yesterday nearly 200 parents were  protesting nevada's school mask mandate  this was last night gathering outside of  ccsd headquarters organizers of this  protest don't want their children forced  to wear masks at school they say it  should be their choice instead  they're the ones who are in charge of  health decisions they know their  children the best and they should be  able to choose whether or not to get  them a vaccine and get them a mask we  don't want to co-parent with the  governor it's child abuse to stick  a face diaper over a child's mouth that  cannot regulate its breathing and all  that properly  statewide guidance issued last week  states k through 12 students they have  to wear masks in school and on the bus  there are exceptions for children with  medical conditions or those with  disabilities